I'm standing on the austere shelter
carrying the largest part of the Dutch
Delta Works it is a mega structure an
enormous dam nine kilometers long
with four kilometers of sluice gates
that can be closed to hold back extreme
high tides and stop the Netherlands
flooding it took a decade to build and
it is a rallying cry of human planning
survival and achievement and it is not
what I'm here to talk about three days
ago a forecast came in a storm is going
to hit winds will gust up to 120
kilometers an hour on this barrier and
so a different rallying cry went up
three words the Cree huh Stern a storm
is coming
because today is ncar techyv in return
the Dutch headwind Cycling Championships
several hundred Dutch people looked at
this weather and said we're going to
have a bike race in that the course is
eight and a half brutal kilometers it's
a serious event with their with
permissions and everything we have a
limit of 300 participants all the bikes
are the same no gears and just an
ordinary brake and it's a typical Dutch
bike yes two times
very I do triathlon in my spare time and
it's just as hard at high speed up to
90% of the drag on a cyclist is from air
resistance and I naively assumed because
it's been 15 years since I study high
school physics that it would be an equal
action reaction thing double the wind
speed double the drag but that's only
true when there's no turbulence in a
situation like this the drag increases
with the square of wind speed double the
wind speed quadruple the drag force the
difference between cycling in a 15
kilometer an hour headwind and a hundred
and twenty kilometre an hour gust is 64
times be added and sure it's a good
weird human interest story right people
are doing a deliberately difficult thing
and hurting themselves just enough that
it's interesting but this is a good
place for it because not only a human's
literally pushing against the storm and
saying we can beat you there on a
physical monument to doing just that
there's a big rock in the middle of a
barrier with an inscription that
translates as here the tide is ruled by
the wind the moon and us
you